i'm on amy you can hear me i sure can
thank you we're just before we start we
just have to pause so we can go live on
youtube
and we will be streaming on rogers tv as
well
so we'll just wait a minute or two so we
can make sure that we are live on both
those channels
i'll just give a shout out to our asl
assistants thank you very much for
helping us today hopefully won't make it
too busy
good afternoon everyone
thank you for joining the ottawa police
for this update to the community on the
ongoing demonstration
remarks will be followed by a brief
media availability
mercedes-benz
today we will have remarks from ottawa
police chief slowly and deputy chief
steve bell
no confirmation
peter slowly
steve
and on that note
i will let chief peter solly give his
remarks
thank you very much amy
good afternoon and thank you everybody
for joining us here today
today i want to update you on our
efforts to put an end to the unlawful
occupation
first i want to talk about our request
for additional resources
to the two levels of government province
and federal
we're working with these levels of
government as well as our policing
partners to secure additional help
there are positive ongoing discussions
that have happened over the last two
days
i want to reinforce
more reinforcements more resources
means a faster set of results to end
this unlawful demonstration
over the last 24 hours we've continued
to do everything we have with the
resources that we have to reduce the
footprint of the occupation and the
effects of the demonstration and the
unlawful conduct around the
demonstration through a combination of
negotiation and enforcement in
particular i can report that
we have negotiated departure of 12
trucks from the coventry road encampment
and 10 trucks from the wellington
footprint
firewood and fuel continue to be
interdicted and seized criminal charges
are being laid in relation to these
activities
there have been over 1 700 tickets
issued
there have been a total of 25 arrests to
date including criminal charges for
mischief and menacing behavior
we have 126 active criminal
investigations and we have over 400 hate
incidents that have been reported to our
hate hotline all of which are being
investigated
we are making progress
and the key to success again is more
resources to safely lawfully and swiftly
end this demonstration
we expect that many demonstrators are
considering coming to the city this
weekend
please do not come
for those of you that are planning to
come here and commit offenses don't
there will be
accountability for any unlawful criminal
activities that occur in this city in
relation to this demonstration
the audible police service will continue
to deploy our surge in and contain
strategy
hardening the downtown core
and deploying all available resources
we know that the residents of ottawa are
angry we know that you are tired we know
that you want your neighborhoods back
you have suffered and we will ensure
those responsible face the consequences
the audible police service our city of
ottawa partners and our policing
partners from all three levels of
government are doing everything in our
power to put an end to this unlawful
occupation
i want to thank every member of our
service you have stepped up in every
manageable way to protect our residents
and keep our cities safe our city and
our service owe each of you an
immeasurable debt of gratitude thank you
i also want to thank all community
members
organizations service providers and
public officials who have worked in
support of our efforts to date
thank you and i'm prepared to take
questions at this point
did deputy
chief steve bell has some comments
before we move to questions or did you
want to move to questions right away
no thanks amy i'm here to support the
chief in answering any sort of questions
okay great thank you
so we'll proceed by alphabetical order
with media outlets we'll be beginning
with our local media then we will be
going to national media you may ask one
question each
and it's a reminder to put your
microphone on mute until i invite you to
ask your question
please do not raise your hand we do have
a list that we will be following
we have 15 to 20 minutes
forever
if you have a question
uh mr slowly uh you were estimating uh
the cost per day at the beginning of the
uh of the protests at roughly 800 000
per day are we at the same number is
that meaning
does that mean that we're over 10
million and plus
of extra cost
of police services
thank you very much for your question
um it has been fluctuating between 700
and 800 thousand dollars as more police
resources have been coming in those
costs are increasing
um
so your your your
your number is accurate based on the
estimate that we've been given however
again we have still not received all the
total costs to date
that's likely going to be on the low
side
merci thank you
we will now go to cbc and i have geek
and vil
so gee
you can ask a question
hello can you hear me
we sure can go ahead thank you so much
for your time um
as you mentioned chief you know citizens
of ottawa are facing the prospect of a
third straight weekend of of these
demonstrators
which tends to be the most ramped up
time of activity
and you also touched on the expected
reinforcements or the the request for
them anyway but i'm still not hearing
exactly when
uh those reinforcements are going to
arrive in particular if they're going to
arrive in time for the weekend and that
period of heightened activity i mean we
heard today that the rcmp will be
sending reinforcements but do you have
any new information on
when
rcmp reinforcements or reinforcements
from any other agency
will actually be part of your response
on the ground and
do you hope
to
further reduce the footprint of the
demonstration
and also
get rid of the supply and
supply
satellite sites that are also cropping
up
this weekend or soon after
uh with the help of those reinforcements
should they actually arrive this weekend
thank you and i as i said more resources
more reinforcements means more results
quicker results safer results but thank
you uh yes i can i can advise
the 250 rcmp officers that were
announced on monday at our board meeting
we continue to swear them in on a daily
basis and deploy them into our
operations
they've been incredibly helpful already
two of their officers in addition to
helping with the demonstration
used narcan to save a life
we are expecting from the gtha a number
of public order units that are will be
arriving in in the next 12 hours and
over the next uh 48 hours to reinforce
our public order units that are already
in the city
there is a provincial uh operation being
run by the ontario provincial police
coordinated by commissioner tom karik
that is helping to triage resources uh
here in the city and across the province
different locations where there are
other aspects of this demonstration
taking place there is a strong level of
coordination and communication between
all three levels of policing and public
safety agencies and we're expecting more
announcements around resources coming
into the city as they arrive they will
continue to advance our efforts to end
this demonstration as quickly and as
safely as possible
thank you merci
will now go to city news
alex gouge
alex you'll be able to ask your question
shortly
and then following alex we going to see
tv and i do believe we have two so if we
could just have one of you raise your
hands so we know we'll be asking a
question thank you
go ahead alex
hello so i was just wondering what's the
rationale for allowing an encampment to
be set up at 1500 bronson when the
overall goal is to get these
demonstrators to leave the city
thank you very much alex for your
question i'm going to ask
deputy chief steve bell to respond first
on that
uh yes thank you very much chief thanks
very much um alex for the question
so um in the very early days of the very
outset of the
uh freedom convoy that started and to
come across canada and all of our
planning around that we identified
several locations within the city where
we were looking to have overflow trucks
park in the attempts to actually
establish locations for trucks to park
so that we could have people transported
downtown to be engaged in what would
have been considered a typical or more
normal demonstration
those
areas were communicated to the convoys
as they were coming across through
communications with our police liaison
team
and what has happened as it has as the
week has progressed uh that location
that you spoke of has been now taken up
by some people to be used um to be used
to to supply and support uh the ongoing
illegal occupation i can tell you that
that's something we've identified and
it's something we actively work on
through negotiations and through
enforcement efforts to stop those supply
depots
great thank you and i see that the jain
from ctv
so
me you'll be able to
ask your question shortly
and i see that global news ottawa is
logged on if you do have a question i'm
going to ask global to raise your hand
so that we know that you'll be next
thank you
jamie
you may go ahead
either can hear me
sure um
so
i understand you say that enforcement is
happening you're making arrests uh
you're working to reduce the
occupation's footprint um
but i believe in what i've heard from a
lot of residents that are still walking
the streets downtown in the core seeing
wellington street seeing everything
that's happening here
um
it's hard for them to understand and see
um
how things are being reduced how we're
seeing the size come down there's still
a significant amount of trucks out there
what's your your what do you say to
those people that feel as though nothing
is being done right now and what's the
plan to get all of these trucks out
i appreciate that very much jeremy and
sometimes it is very difficult
particularly those who've been
unlawfully victimized and traumatized
for the length of time in the nature in
which some of the more menacing and
hateful incidents unfolded in the very
first weekend so i can completely
emphasize and understand that
we can though remember that on the
saturday when the first
large portion of the demonstration
occurred there were some 3 000 plus
trucks
as high as as low as 7 000 an estimate
as high as 15 000 in terms of
participants in the demonstration
uh we saw by the next weekend the number
of trucks had been down to 1 000 and the
highest number i saw was five thousand
including counter demonstrations
saturday being active sunday being
almost uh no demonstrations uh in the
core
uh we're not gonna take any great solace
in those successes of reduction as of
today the number of trucks that are
involved
in the actual redstone footprints is 400
and we removed some 25 of them over the
last 24 hours through negotiation so day
by day we are removing trucks through
negotiation and towing enforcement from
the footprints in the red zone and
around in the in the surrounding
neighborhoods weekend over weekend we
are seeing significant reductions in the
range of 50 to 65 percent of total
trucks and total demonstrators we
continue to harden the city and we
continue to go off of funding go after
funding fuel and other logistics
supports that are enabling the
demonstration to go on we're negotiating
wherever possible and we're enforcing
wherever possible and as we get more
reinforcements more resources we will
get more results and a safer and swifter
end to this unlawful unsafe
demonstration
thank you and then global news i see
that you do have someone so i'll just
ask the reporter to identify themselves
before they ask their question so you
may go ahead global
hi there it's abigail beeman with global
news uh chief solely i'm looking for
some more specifics on the call for more
resources there was you know your call
for 1800
more more bodies with that split i heard
you give the specific of 250 in terms of
rcmp but for that 1800 number where
exactly are you at
so we're still in very constructive and
very productive discussions with
the rcmp the ontario provincial police
the big 12 police agencies here in
ontario
as i mentioned earlier on
uh opp commissioner tom creek has
established a provincial-wide resource
base it is actually working here in
ottawa out of an rcmp building and i
literally just finished a call with with
all three levels of of public safety
agencies including all major police
services here in ontario around the
establishment of that central
coordination hub how it's supporting us
here in the nation's capital as well as
a gta
southern ontario specifically sarnia and
windsor and other locations
either currently having or expecting
demonstrations sympathetic
demonstrations or decentralized
demonstrations that are that are
occurring from this central location
here in ottawa uh there are resources
coming to us i am quite certain of that
we are seeing the resources promised
from the rcmp being sworn in and
deployed in real time and we have uh
information that indicates there'll be
other announcements in the next 24 to 48
hours there are a number of public order
units that are coming from the gtha
police services that will be arriving
today and over the weekend here in
ottawa for immediate deployment i say it
again the more resources the more
reinforcements the safer and quicker we
can end this unlawful and unsafe
demonstration here in the city
thank you merci we're now going to go to
the hua
natwan
it will be challenging
followed by frederick
um you say um that
you negotiated the removal of 12 trucks
at coventry road and another 10 trucks
left
downtown core are we talking about the
big one the pickup trucks first of all
and when you talk about negotiated the
removal
what what did you say to them for them
to leave
well thank you very much and yes when i
reference
those vehicles that left those are all
trucks the large trucks
the negotiations have been ongoing
literally ongoing from before the first
convoys arrived in ottawa and in every
one of those cases we have reinforced
that demonstrators arriving here need to
do so peacefully need to do so lawfully
and if they intend to do anything
otherwise unlawful they should not come
otherwise they will face consequences
in every one of the negotiations we have
tried to find a peaceful and lawful way
for individuals or groups of individuals
including the vehicles and conveyances
that they've brought here to leave
peacefully lawfully
um we have also been very clear that
unlawful behavior will be met with
consequences in the cases that we talked
about in the last 24 hours we were able
through a very skilled and dedicated
group of police liaison officers and
expert negotiators that have been
brought in from across the province to
convince people who feel that they came
here have made their points are now
suffering potentially jeopardy for any
unlawful activity to return to their
homes and bring their vehicles with them
and that's what we we've reported on
today that has continued from every day
since we started and it will continue to
the very last day when the very last
truck and demonstrator leaves here
either through negotiation or through
enforcement
merci thank you now we're going to
frederick cafe
oh hi chief slowly so yesterday you guys
sent a release saying that uh protesters
that
blocked the streets they could they
could be fined they can even face
arrests
a few days prior you guys were saying
people that are bringing gas in you
could be arrested
so we still see these gat this gas being
brought in and we still see trucks that
are blocking the streets
so what's the strategy here chief slowly
thank you frederick um and you're
absolutely right we are not able with
the resources that we have right now to
interdict all the sources of supports
that are going to the demonstrators when
we get more resources we will be able to
take out fully those supply bases we
will be able to fully interdict those
people bringing in gas canisters will be
able to deploy enough resources to tag
and tow and arrest those people who are
committing bylaw offenses provincial
offenses or federal offenses
particularly criminal code offenses that
is exactly why we made the resource
request of the 1800 resources and that
is why we're grateful for the support of
the mayor and the chair for the letters
that they sent to the provincial
government and the federal government
and that is why i have spent every day
since this demonstration started trying
to get more resources
more resources more reinforcements means
more results a speedier safer more
lawful end to this unlawful and unsafe
demonstration
thank you we'll now be going to ctv
national and bergeron
followed by global male christie kirkl
so any shouldn't be long you can go
ahead and ask your question
hi thank you very much for taking my
question there are still hundreds of
trucks in the downtown core as you
mentioned and you talked earlier this
week about the inability to get tow
trucks to get onside to help ottawa
police move them have any of the tow
truck operators including any of those
previously contracted to work with
police have they been amenable to moving
trucks if asked by ottawa police and if
not why
thank you annie it's a great question
um i can tell you this one at least one
of the major tow trucks that would have
been able to supply us with the
logistics to tow
illegal vehicles and to significant
degree
reduce the size of the demonstration
has been threatened themselves
they have been threatened through some
sophisticated online activities and
direct threats to harm to their
employees and their business
there is a full criminal investigation
going into those threats
in other cases we have had uncooperative
private sector uh agents that we've
contacted
um and so it's been incredibly difficult
again i was on a call with the chiefs of
police from across
the province i've heard from the chief
of police in windsor has faced exactly
the same problems uncooperative
agents down there or people who
themselves have been threatened to not
participate and support in police
operations to remove the demonstrators
that are blocking the international
bridge to the united states we've heard
this from kutz alberta from the rcmp
operations out there this is a
significant logistical impasse and we're
doing everything we can to get past it
we have looked at all sorts of options
and we're looking at all sorts of joint
procurement efforts including across the
country and south of the border
we are considering other methods that
may allow us to not need to use tow
trucks to the extent we initially
thought
all options are on the table
thank you and we'll be going to the
globe and mail christy per kirkup
followed by the national post ryan
tumulty
it won't be long it'll be christy
and we will come back to cbc national
stephen hoff after so to be globe and
mail christy national post brian and in
cbc nationals
hi good afternoon uh chief slowly i'm
wondering how concerned are you about
the fact that some of the organizers
involved in the convoy
have military and rcmp backgrounds and
i'm wondering to what extent has this
contributed to
uh reluctance or any reluctance to be
more aggressive in terms of enforcement
efforts
christie let me be clear
there is no reluctance to be involved in
enforcement efforts
we have been enforcing the law from day
one and we continue to do so as more
resources become available as we move
the size of the demonstration and
contained it to greater degrees we've
redeployed those resources into
enforcement our charges are up our
arrests are up we're towing more trucks
and we're able to be able to demonstrate
to negotiate with demonstrators in a
more forceful way
so again enforcement has and will
continue to increase as resources become
more available
in regards to the capabilities of of the
overarching demonstration
um i've been clear from the beginning
this is an unprecedented demonstration
it has significant levels of fundraising
coordination communication they have
command centers established here and
across the country and beyond this
country the level of capability that i'm
talking about has been validated by our
national security agencies who have
already given us a briefing again today
that reinforces the very question that
you've asked this is an entirely
sophisticated level of of demonstrators
they have the capability to run strong
organization
here
provincially and nationally and we're
seeing that play out in real time so it
is a significant concern it is a
significant risk that we're trying to
mitigate and overcome and as we get more
resources we will get better results
we now go to the national post
ryan timothy so ryan
you'll be able to ask your question now
yeah hi there chief i'm i'm wondering of
the request you made for 1800 officers
earlier this week
um how much of that request has been
fulfilled or do you suspect to be
fulfilled
and
is do you need more support particularly
from either the federal or provincial
side of that equation is one side doing
more than the other
thank you very much for your question
ryan again uh incredibly productive and
constructive discussions that have been
taking place in person in this city
both levels of government have sent some
of their best people to participate in
those discussions from very tactically
focused commanders who understand the
ground to strategic level commanders
with years of experience but understand
that
the difficulties of logistics and
airlifting hundreds if not thousands of
people from across the province and
across the country into a location like
this and down in the south of ontario uh
in windsor uh we are making progress we
are seeing more people from the original
250 that the rcmp
announced uh on monday uh we are seeing
more opp officers mobilized um i'm
expecting announcements in the next 24
to 48 hours from both levels of
governments in regards to the additional
resources that we requested two days ago
i am confident that we will get some
results but the quicker those results
come the quicker those resources come
the quicker we will get safer results to
an end of the unlawful demonstration
here
thank you and we have time for two more
questions we'll be going to cbc national
with stephen hoff followed by canadian
press
uh jim bronskill so those will be our
last two questions
so steven you'll be up you can ask your
one question go ahead
hi chiefs thanks for taking my question
i'm wondering i know ottawa police are
working with ottawa bylaw have they also
been working with ministry of
transportation officers to do
inspections on the trucks i'm also
hoping you can comment on the issues 911
was having and whether you can directly
relate that to convoy activity thank you
so much
stephen thank you um and if i've
forgotten any one of your questions just
please remind me let me go on reverse
order please um we are quite certain
that the um excessive calls that almost
jammed our 911
call system last night were coming in
from um elements that are supporting
the core demonstrations here and across
the country they were coming in from the
united states not exclusively but
significantly from united states based
addresses
we've worked hard overnight our
dispatchers have put in contingencies to
move those calls away so we can still
dispatch resources to emergency calls
and to support our demonstrations those
efforts of swatting and doxing our
organizations and logistics have been
ongoing throughout this demonstration
and have represented a major challenge
to us in managing this these are tactics
that we've seen deployed in other
locations across north america and
they're being employed here
um sorry if you could just repeat your
other two questions please sir
just one other question are you uh
working with ministry of transportation
inspections to escort them into the zone
and look at
possible violations there i know this
was done in quebec city last weekend i'm
just wondering if it's happening here
yes thank you very much um and in fact
it was the quebec city example that we
were looking to leverage
uh literally at the same time we had the
demonstration down in the gta toronto
specifically and then in the last 48
hours we've seen demonstrations in
windsor sarnia and i think two other
locations in the province we are all now
seeking the supports of the mto around
similar demonstrations mto is trying to
triage all of the requests that are
coming in from ottawa the gtha in
southern ontario um and that's a
challenge that we're having right now to
make sure that we're getting the right
request triage and the right response
from a central uh logistical support
from the mto
thank you and now we're going to go to
canadian press
jim bronskill jim you may go ahead
yes uh
the fourth credit auto release last
night that basically said uh the trucks
blocking streets are breaking the law
and could be impounded could be uh
confiscated i think some are wondering
why isn't that happening now or at least
why aren't the drivers parked blocking
roads being arrested
and you can worry about the trucks later
thank you very much jim and again i'll
go back to it we have been making
arrests of people who are unlawfully
driving or using their vehicles in any
way a range of arrests and charges have
been made
that will continue as it has from the
first day to the last day and
investigations and prosecutions of those
who broke the law particularly the
criminal law will continue in perpetuity
until they're brought into justice in
one way or the other no matter where
they live in in this country
i'll come back to it again as soon as we
get more resources that we can free up
from reducing the size of the
demonstration we apply those resources
immediately to enforcement of those laws
we have made a significant request to
the two other levels of government for
significant more resources when they
arrive here they will immediately apply
to those enforcement activities so that
we can make good on those consequences
as quickly as possible and end this
unlawful demonstration as quickly and as
safely and as lawfully as possible thank
you so much for your question sir
that ends the time we have today
our statement
[Music]
[Music]
and those we apologize to the media we
did not get to you will be prioritized
on our next media availability
position
please remember to put the media that
you are with so we can
ensure that all media have questions
so um chief and deputy you you can go
and i'll provide a french
statement to those that are online for
french
um
we ask your questions
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
exactly
[Music]
[Music]
excessive
foreign
okay